de quoi s'agit il
mais leur existence va prendre sa vente
anne je présente mes garçons notre
direction
voici mon fils max sans rancune hein
j'essaie d'entamer un nouveau chapitre
de ma vie
elle vient avec moi mes amis n'ont pas
de maillot je vais à miami nouveau car à
la maison une belle famille cet hiver il
faut pas mal à miami qui l'empêché de
faire sa demande j'ai appelé non c'est
la phrase qui fait trembler le monde
entier
ils devront aller très très loin
attendait c'est quoi pour garder leur
famille unie forte et johnson 3 présente
il a dit quelque chose
non l'équipe punk ce fond la caisse à
une soirée tranquille
comment il a cassé l'ambiance